un petit mot sur un sujet qui concerne
la vraie réalité les normes
il y à 7000 traités internationaux en
france il y a dix sept mille textes
communautaires 11000 loi 127 milles
décret 400000 normes
or notre système en france c'est que
toutes les normes s'appliquent de
manière égalitaire sur l'ensemble du
territoire
aujourd'hui on arrive un système de
blocage de cixi d'exaspération des
territoires ruraux
on l'a analysé avec un symptôme de
parlementaire et ce que nous proposons
ici c'est de créer un nouveau principe
juridique d'adaptation qui est un
principe qui serait de valeur
constitutionnelle
on a vu 5 le conseil d'état et le
conseil constitutionnel ce qui
permettrait dans les départements ruraux
notamment pour lé préfet d'avoir une
certaine marge d'appréciation pour
mettre en application un certain nombre
de dérogations ou d'adaptation ça
permettrait de libérer d'auxi jean et
d'oxygéner nos territoires qui sont
aujourd'hui à succès partout partout ces
textes voilà ce que je